Welcome back to human emotion.
So this is our final and third segment.
Looking at the ways in which emotion can go awry and trying to understand how
the basic processes and functions of emotion may sometimes literally unravel and
fall apart.
So today what we're going to be talking about is psychosis as well as
personality disorders and the way in which they represent,
um,
the ways emotion can go awry or unravel.
So our roadmap today will go as follows.
We'll start by looking at schizophrenia as a window into understanding psychosis
and emotion.
Next we'll turn turn to borderline personality disorder is a key candidate
personality disorder that really exemplifies difficulties in both emotional
reactivity on the one hand and emotion regulation on the other.
Then we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's begin first with schizophrenia,
perhaps one of the most mysterious,
the most elusive,
and yet the most complex and difficult to treat,
perhaps of all emotional disorders.
So when we think of schizophrenia and we turned to our three themes of emotion
and psychopathology,
the theme that's really gained prominence is not extremes or absences.
But as this notion at the bottom,
as you can see in yellow of disjunctions,
so this is this notion that we have this multi componential emotion response
system was subjective behavioral and physiological response components,
and that is schizophrenia.
What might be going on is that these channels are not aligning or they're not
matching up correctly,
so we're going to delve into precisely what way these emotion channels aren't
mapping up and what this tells us about the emotional nature inner life of
individuals with this severe and costly psychiatric disorder,
schizophrenia.
If we delve into the DSM and we look at the diagnostic criteria,
what we see on the left is a broad category that really encapsulates wide
sweeping disruptions in thought and behavior and in emotion.
And in particular when we look at these three categories,
we see things that are really broken down into three symptom clusters,
positive symptoms including delusions,
hallucinations and disorganized speech,
negative symptoms including flat affect,
a lack of pleasure,
lack of motivation and disorganize symptoms secure.
We get into the sort of really kind of dark or mysterious realm of thought
disorder and derailment.
Importantly,
schizophrenia is chronic or long term.
So it has to have a duration of at least six months minimum in order to warrant
a diagnosis of schizophrenia.
And like all emotional disorders we've talked about so far,
it causes severe and chronic impairment.
So I want to walk through some of these categories of symptoms that were just
alluded to in the Dsm to flesh them out a bit more.
So first is the category of disorganized symptoms.
So this is disorganization or incoherence of cognition and behavior.
So this is thought of on the one hand,
in terms of disorganized speech or what's been called formal thought disorder.
So this can be manifested in terms of incoherence.
So inability to try to organize ideas,
um,
loose associations.
So kind of grabbing it ideas and bringing them together in a way that may not
make logical sense to the rest of the world as well as a very kind of fragmented
or nonlinear progression of thinking.
Importantly,
you also see disorganized behavior.
So you see odd or unusual kinds of peculiar behaviors that don't necessarily map
onto the kinds of behaviors you see amongst the rest of the general population.
Second are what are called positive symptoms.
So John Nash in a beautiful mind really exemplified some of these symptoms.
Um,
so the positive though importantly is a misnomer.
So by positive what these mean or an excess or distortion of normal functioning.
And there's different types of positive symptoms.
There's three that you can see here.
One are delusions,
so these are erroneous beliefs so you can have beliefs of persecutory.
So believing that people are out to get you.
Um,
these are very common in schizophrenia.
Referential thoughts,
grandiosity,
unusual religious thinking as well as sematic things.
So people may think for referentiality that things that are arranged in a room
or coming from the TV or newspaper are especially targeted towards them
personally.
They may also have ideas of grandiosity where they think they have special
powers to do things that no one else can do or have special religious,
um,
you know,
insights,
our relationships with God that no one else has.
Um,
second positive symptom are hallucinations.
So these are perceiving things visually,
auditorily,
olfactory,
gustatory,
any of your major senses you're picking up on something that isn't necessarily
there or that other people do not perceive to be there.
Um,
so you're perceiving them in the absence of external sensory stimulation or
input.
And then finally is disorganized speech and behavior.
So here we get into thought,
thought disorder.
So not being able to coherently organize your thoughts or your behaviors,
they're kind of in a very confusing,
perhaps a jumbled mishmash.
Um,
and then the third category is negative symptoms.
And again,
negatives,
really a misnomer.
So what we're talking about here is a deficit or lack of or dimunition of normal
functioning.
So types of negative symptoms can include poverty of speech,
a lack of motivation or goal directed activity,
a lack of pleasure,
Anhedonia.
And importantly,
what I've started at the bottom,
because it's most relevant to emotion research,
is what's called flat affect or a sort of lack of outward expressions.
You can see the picture of this young woman who showing what we would think of
as flat AFX.
So showing minimal emotion,
expressive in her face.
Now what I want to do is just show you a very brief three minute video and think
about which symptoms that you might see this video.
Are you seeing positive symptoms,
negative symptoms,
or disorganized symptoms?
So take a look here,
take some notes and think about what you're seeing and also think about the
nature of emotional symptoms that might be emerging in this particular video.
Fantastic,
expensive equipment.
They said to me,
hey,
we can,
uh,
we can check your
security from that injury or on its own
kind of thing.
And
they put the needle in the last one.
They put it like this.
So when they did it,
I had a thought.
And when they pulled him out,
they pull them up.
Burn.
But they left a little teeny little Barb and all,
every one of the places they put me and they recorded it.
And one person who wanted it,
didn't someone else sold it to someone else.
I don't know who,
but they're able to give a response back because of the,
the how thick the dental is in my teeth.
I take the Dowel is,
and,
uh,
the needles,
they're easy to focus,
a heavier field of pickup reception because of all the feelings I got.
And so I am,
I think it's people like at Stanford
and,
uh,
technicians,
a wealthy technicians,
and people that do stuff like Nasa Ames institute.
I came right up to them and tried to sell them that last little,
but for the amount of money they didn't have,
I have just gave it to him.
I like watching a doctor,
you Mr. Rogers,
and they like my family.
And I know it was a problem with my dad would just say she didn't just go leave
him alone because this way the situation was,
he never had too many arrests.
So I'm the one that's gotta go a little,
I had a rough ups.
Yeah.
Hey,
what'd you do that for?
Why did he go like this?
First I wanted to make it green.
Right?
Oh,
oh.
And then they can all agree the spot there,
you know?
Ah,
full.
You know.
But uh,
uh,
that's just so adorable.
We were okay.
Okay.
So early observations of flat aspect discussing schizophrenia.
We're really pioneered by boiler who said that even in the less severe forms of
the illness,
there seem to be an observable indifference that seemed to be the external sign
of their state and indifference to everything,
to friends and relations to vocation and enjoyment to duties or rights or two
good fortune.
So there was an early observation about the emotional life of individuals,
the schizophrenia that assumed that patients with schizophrenia must have
diminished internal experience because they weren't showing anything on their
face.
It must mean that they had a really diminished internal emotional life as well.
Now,
this had been the assumption for most of the 19 hundreds until a pioneering
researcher came in and creating from the University of California at Berkeley
who really thought of emotions,
schizophrenia.
She called it as an old mystery and pioneered a very new understanding of the
emotional life of people with schizophrenia.
So she talked about this notion of flat affect and schizophrenia.
So in other words,
that in their emotional behavior,
indeed,
when she took the tools of emotion science,
brought patients with schizophrenia into lab.
Indeed she shot,
she saw that they show fewer facial expressions of emotions to films and
pictures compared to controls.
But,
and this is the really critical part of her discoveries.
They reported similar or even more intense internal emotion experience.
So even though they weren't showing anything on their face,
they actually reporting a very vivid and rich internal emotional life.
So this what and cream pioneered is this really fascinating disjunction between
emotion experience.
On the lefthand side,
we're individuals with schizophrenia do report comparable internal emotion,
uh,
two controls
from their outward emotional behavior where they seem to be expressing very
little or very subtle signs of emotionality.
And she called this a disjunction right between these two response components.
She really completely fired up the field to suggest that we've been making
mistakes all along and assuming they don't experience emotion in the same way as
the rest of us,
she said,
indeed they do.
They're just not showing it in their face.
Another important component of schizophrenia to know and think about as the home
context that these individuals are often associated with.
And this is this notion by Jill Hooli at Harvard University of expressed emotion
or II.
So she would ask the question of why do patients with schizophrenia seem to be
more likely to return to the hospital after discharge if they're living with
their families than not?
So why wouldn't they be more supported and comforted?
And what she found is that looking at expressed emotion and family discussions,
which she found is that there's often hostility expressed in these family
interactions towards a patient of Chris at criticism of the patient and over
protective overinvolved attitudes.
This is really the question of which comes first is it that the symptoms of
schizophrenia create unusual thoughts and the patient that that generate
increased critical comments from the family or do increase critical comments
from the family really trigger the onset of unusual patient thoughts.
And this is of tricky by directional relationship,
but it just suggests that part of the symptoms we see in schizophrenia,
you know,
may be emerging from the home life.
And so is home really home sweet home in individuals with schizophrenia.
And with this research has found is that individuals and families who are high
expressed emotion as opposed to those who are low and express emotion actually
have uh,
and fare worse outcomes.
So this is percent relapse here on the access for up to 60%,
and you're seeing a higher rate of relapse and individuals who are in a high
expressed emotion environment who are in yellow spending a high amount of time
or high contact with their family.
Um,
so if you're in that kind of environment,
it's especially pernicious and predicts relapse much greater if you're spending
more time with the partners.
So on high he families contact may actually be bad for individuals,
whereas in low e families contact and be so supportive,
buffer or good for patients.
So now we're going to quickly turn to borderline personality disorder.
So borderline personality started as part of a broader category of what we call
access to personality disorders.
This includes also mental retardation,
but when we zoom in on personality disorders,
really what's important to know about them as they have a longstanding duration.
These are things that emerge early in life.
They're pervasive and thought of as being relatively inflexible patterns of
behavior and inner experience.
They deviate markedly from cultural expectations or norms.
And this pattern leads to clinically significant distress or impairment across
multiple domains of functioning.
And this should be manifested in at least two of the following cognitive effect
of interpersonal functioning or impulse control and is not due to another mental
disorder.
So there are lots of overlap between different personalities orders,
but I just want to show you the three broad clusters that have been discussed
with respect to personality disorders.
There's cluster a odd or eccentric cluster,
be dramatic or erratic in cluster c,
anxious or fearful.
And although this is not a class in abnormal psychology,
what I'd like to do is just orient this to you to highlight in on what we're
going to talk about today,
which is borderline personality disorder here.
So we're going to talk about borderline personality disorder because it's a
really prominent and important persona sorta that really exemplifies core
difficulties in emotion,
reactivity and regulation.
So if we look at the DSM criteria for borderline personality disorder,
what we see here is this idea of um,
really,
you know,
impulsive,
unstable,
stormy relationships,
unstable sense of self.
And as you can see here,
emotion regulation,
problems and of core,
part of what might be triggering this people think is a very difficult home
environment.
So having an early environment where behavioral patterns are fueled by parental
punishing,
ignoring a child's needs,
but on the one hand attending to behavioral outbursts.
So when we think about these things have emotion regulation difficulties,
how do they exactly look in borderline personality disorder when we apply the
sort of lens of emotion science.
So what research has shown is that in borderline percentage,
sort of what we're seeing is heightened emotion or activity,
particularly for negative emotions as well as difficulty regulating emotions,
having a really unstable,
positive and negative emotional repertoire.
So I'll give you some key pieces of example before we wrap up today.
So in one study that was recently published,
um,
they talked about borderline personality disorder as really thinking about it as
volatility from negative to positive and back again.
So what they did is they followed individuals with bipolar disorder over the
course of a 21 day experience sampling diary.
And they had people self report using something like a palm pilot.
Their daily experience of both positive and negative emotion and using really
sophisticated multilevel modeling techniques.
What they found that was most diagnostic of borderline personality disorder was
a rapid oscillation over the course of the week between positive and negative
emotion.
So they said,
what really seems to be a core feature of borderline percentage order is the
unstable almost,
you know,
vicissitudes of the emotions going up and down and back again.
Um,
there's also been neuroimaging studies that look at Amygdala activity and
borderline personality disorder.
Again,
we talked about this as a brain region associated with both emotional salients
and potentially as a fear center and what we're seeing in borderline personality
disorders,
what seems to be a Migdal a hyper activity.
So we see increased activity for example,
in response to an effect of pictures and fearful faces get also having a reduced
volume of the Amygdala as well.
Importantly,
we also see reduced volume in prefrontal cognitive control regions like the
media and orbital prefrontal cortex.
And the,
we see failure of active engagement and response to negative or trauma related
scripts.
Um,
we also see things like reduced,
um,
you know,
uh,
functioning or you know,
adaptive functioning in the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex.
Again,
another prefrontal cognitive control regions.
So we see increased activity in response to pain stimuli,
but a failure of adaptive activation response to trauma scripts.
So what we're seeing is both at the self reported behavioral and neurological
level,
you know,
difficulties with reactivity and difficulty regulating emotions that seem to be
unstable and wavering between positive and negative emotion extremes.
Borderline personality disorder has been depicted widely in the media.
Um,
but in one particular movie,
um,
you know,
the,
uh,
with the Angelina Jolie and Bruno and a writer girl interrupted,
we see a lot of discussion and portrayals of what borderline personal disorder
looks like.
Um,
the treatment of borderline personality disorder.
It really has been pioneered by Marsha Linehan at the University of Washington
who developed what's called dialectical behavior therapy or DBT,
where the goal here is to reach what she calls a state of wise mind or a balance
between both rational and emotional states.
And she has four main modules of dialectical behavior therapy that include
mindfulness.
So observing emotions without judging them.
Second,
interpersonal effectiveness.
So being assertive,
saying,
knowing how to say no,
make a request,
coping with life stressors effectively.
Third distress tolerance.
And fourth,
and most importantly to what we've been talking about today,
teaching individuals with borderline personality disorder,
how to effectively regulate emotions by both labeling them,
managing them,
and trying to increase experiences of healthy,
positive emotions.
So I want to just conclude since this is our last lecture on emotional
disorders,
that by reminding ourselves that even though we've characterized many ways that
emotions can be experienced,
two extreme or relative deficits or even disjunction among emotion response
components,
that this is simply characterizing differences in the ways emotions are
manifested in ways they cause difficulties for people from anxiety disorders to
mood disorders,
schizophrenia to even personality disorders.
But this doesn't imply that there's any judgment as to what is the best or most
ideal emotion state.
And as Hans Asperger said,
not everything that steps out of line and thus abnormal must necessarily be
inferior.
So with that,
I want to conclude with our takeaway questions.
So the first question from today is as follows,
how does schizophrenia represent an example of emotion,
disjunction and what channels and specifically or in particularly is the emotion
disjunction between second,
in what way is emotion,
reactivity and regulation impaired and borderline personality disorder.
And finally,
what are the four core modules in DBT for treating borderline personality
disorder,
especially with respect to emotion related difficulties.
Finally,
now we're going to conclude with our expert interview as part of the experts in
emotion interview series.
Um,
we'll be speaking with doctor and crying,
a professor of psychology at the University of California,
Berkeley and a member of the Institute for Personality and Social Research on
schizophrenia and emotion.
Dr. King received a BS in psychology from Ball State University and her MBA and
phd in clinical psychology from the State University of New York at Stony Brook.
Dr [inaudible] research focuses on emotion and psych pathology with a specific
interest in the emotional features of schizophrenia,
assessing negative symptoms of schizophrenia and the linkage between cognition
and emotion and schizophrenia.
In addition,
she also studies emotion healthy individuals with a focus on individual
differences and expressive behavior,
gender differences and emotion and linkages between cognition,
personality,
social context and emotion.
Dr [inaudible] has received numerous awards including a young investigator award
from the national lines for research on schizophrenia and depression,
the Joseph Subin Memorial Fund Award and the Distinguished Teaching Award from
UC Berkeley.
She's currently president elect for the Society for research in psychopathology
and has served as an associate editor for the journal that normal psychology as
well as cognition and emotion and a member of the editorial boards for
schizophrenia bulletin psychological science and the public interest and applied
and preventative psychology,
emotion and Journal of research in personality.
She's also the author or editor of three books and several scholarly papers in
top journals in the field.
So I now turn to our special experts in emotion interview with doctor and crane
on schizophrenia and emotion
for experts and emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr. David Watson on personality and emotion.
Dr. Watson is the Andrew Mckenna family professor of psychology at the
University of Notre Dame.
Dr. Watson is a personality psychologist with particular expertise in
personality assessment.
His work investigates the structure and measurement of personality,
mood,
and psychopathology,
as well as examining how personality traits relate to clinical disorders.
He works in a variety of substantive areas within psychopathology,
including depression and the anxiety disorders,
personality disorders,
schism,
tippy,
and asleep,
and associated disorders.
The longterm goal of his work is to develop comprehensive taxonomic models that
integrate normal range and pathological processes into a single overarching
scheme.
Dr. Watson has published more than 100 articles in the top journals in
psychology,
including the Journal of personality and Social Psychology,
the journal of abnormal psychology,
psychological bulletin,
and psychological assessment.
And he's currently serves as editor and chief of the Journal of abnormal
psychology.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with Dr. David
Watson on personality and emotion.